that last call is a very interesting
topic this topic of financial infidelity
Redbook magazine did a survey that said
38% of you lie to your spouse about
money Wow and you wonder why your
marriage isn't topping out is it awesome
now I mean it can be little white lies
the target bags under the bed snicker
snicker right or it can be big-time
credit card debt it can be one of yous
running a business and is running up
debt down at the business and not
telling your spouse because you're
trying to live your dream and it's
turning into a nightmare let me just
kind of clarify this for you there is no
positive effect to your marriage when
you lie to your spouse was that helpful
you didn't already know that did you
yeah well I'm trying to avoid a fight
you're all you're doing is cooking it up
it's gonna be a bigger fight once it
cooks up you might as well have a
smaller fight quickly so here's the
thing if you're afraid to discuss with
your spouse a purchase or a financial
issue that you want to discuss that is
not a financial problem that's a
relationship problem now I got to tell
you there's
times I mean I I have a ton of money I'm
a multimillionaire as timeso I think I
want to buy something and I'm gonna sit
down and talk sure and hey I wanna buy
this toy I'm gonna buy another gun she's
like you don't need another gun you have
too many guns already people already
would think you were crazy if they knew
how many guns your head I collect guns
by the way so yeah if it ever comes out
you know they're gonna find out that I
was like one of those crazy guys or
something I'm not but I collect okay I
collect so you know you don't need
another car you don't need another boat
you don't need another inner-tube to
pull behind the boat actually collect
those they've got too much too many lake
toys right for the grandkids and for the
kids to play on and so you know I get
ready to buy a toy and it's it's not it
doesn't even show up on our but I still
have to have this moment and I go I
actually got to make sure I talked to
Sharon about this she gets ready to buy
a purse that's too expensive which is
one of the few things that she buys
that's too expensive but like she says
one of those purses is equal to one of
those guns well maybe maybe two guns but
you know in it funny how as adults that
have the money even where there's not a
stress on the finances have it a little
bit of a dread about talking to each
other so you really have to push
yourself and make yourself and Rachel
talks about this in her book love your
life not theirs and one of the seven
habits is talk about money even when
it's hard and it's almost always hard so
talk about it keep it clean and if your
spouse is hiding money from you it
generally does fall under one of three
areas one is you've got a broken
relationship and they are intimidated by
you two the spouse is an arrogant
rebellious immature prince or princess
that just wants to do whatever they want
to do with their little lip stuck out
and they don't like being told no
spoiled child in the grown-up body and
goes and buys whatever they want to buy
but know that it's wrong so they hide it
from you most often we find hidden debt
though it's the what the guy was on the
last
one of the spouses has been given all of
the responsibility all of the weight of
all of the decision-making isn't doing
the money handling well ends up running
into debt because they're not doing a
good job with it and now the shame is
multiplied and it's shame based hiding
its guilty condemnation based hiding so
they're hiding it because they don't
they're ashamed that they haven't done a
good job handling the money in which
case if that's your spouse you are
partially responsible just like that guy
said he was he owned it because he
should have been more involved he
shouldn't dump this on his wife and you
shouldn't dump it all on your husband
you shouldn't dump it all on either one
of you both of you should be involved
now one of you again can carry the
administrative weight once all the
decisions are made
but everybody ought to know where every
dollar is going pretty simple stuff hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]